March third at 722 p.m. I christina
pazsitzky had a double-pipe classic it's
not burp fart what has to be some final
cannes y Philip I plastic double-pipe
classic yeah dad Tom how can I make a
double cyclone well I keep getting
questions about it I mean they happen
literally once maybe every five years
yeah they're not they're not common yo
it's something to be celebrated I would
tell people that would make Facebook
posts i would ya yeah i would share that
that's really cool very rare they're so
rare i keep getting questions every day
on twitter they're like does this count
to that count listen kiss your mother
hug your wife tell people you love them
be a good person and let a double-pipe
to arrive